bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être là ce matin pour débattre de ce
revenu d'engagement qui devrait être
annoncée bientôt par emmanuel macron va
d'abord écouté ce qu'il avait promis le
chef de l'état c'était le 12 juillet
dernier regard des
jeux présentera à la rentrée le revenu
d'engagement pour les jeunes qui
concernera les jeunes sans emploi ou
formation et sera fondé sur une logique
de devoir est de droit car cette logique
ce duo du revenu d'engagement devrait
finalement viser les jeunes de 16 à 25
ans sans emploi sans formation mais
aussi ceux en emploi précaire et ils
recevront 500 euros mais devront
s'engager dans une démarche qui mène
vers l'emploi qu'en pensez vous
contassot finalement ce revenu dans
l'engagement cette promesse ne sera pas
tenu
non c'est du maquereau pur jus cdu et et
en même temps c'est à dire que en même
temps on annonce qu'on va faire quelque
chose en même temps on propose un
dispositif qui touchera quasiment
personne c'est franchement pas sérieux
quand on voit les files d'attentes des
étudiants ou simplement se nourrir quand
on voit à quel point aujourd'hui et ici
avéré depuis déjà pas mal de temps les
étudiants qui sont obligés de travailler
ont de plus en plus de mal à poursuivre
leurs études plus ils travaillent et
moins ils réussissent dans les études
tout ça est totalement documenté donc on
va bien on est très très loin de mettre
en place une mesure qui permettent aux
jeunes de vivre je dirais même presque
de survie dans des conditions normales
et existe finalement les étudiants de ce
dispositif on l'a bien vu ça devait
concerner 1 2 million de jeunes au
départ et finalement ça fera moins de
400 mille david xavier weiss qu'en
pensez vous oui mais c'est justement là
le vrai problème c'est que aujourd'hui
on a des étudiants qui parfois galère
parce qu'ils ont des jobs en alternance
qui travaillent le soir chez orange dans
telle ou telle chaîne de grandes de
restauration rapide et aujourd'hui c'est
à ces jeunes qu'il fallait d'abord
apporter une solution parce que ils sont
logés quand ils font dans leurs études à
paris le logement coûte très cher ou en
région parisienne il ya pas de
modulation des aides en fonction de dieu
de vos études quand vous le faites vos
études à toulouse
parle effectivement ce n'est pas le même
coût de la vie et et moi je préfère
connaître les étudiants parce que c'est
eux qui demain vont pouvoir entre
guillemets rendre à la société ce qu'ils
ont finalement reçu pendant leurs années
d'études et là encore le dispositif
n'est pas complètement exclu jeudi même
pas rien voir ni ni sont exclus du
dispositif
or c'était eux que finalement la
promesse avait été faite et là encore un
reniement de la promesse présidentielle
je trouve ça dommage à quelques mois
d'une présidence à quelques mois de
l'échéance présidentielle de de se
renier tout comme en début de mandat il
avait été élevé n'a pas supprimé synchro
de l'appel cd movie studio clamp vos
étudiants des mauvais signaux qui
l'envoie à ceux qui aujourd'hui font
beaucoup d'efforts qui ont été comme
tout le monde mais peut-être cette
génération un peu plus que d'autres avec
la crise sanitaire qui ont beaucoup
souffert et qui n'ont pas tous pour
certains trouvaient justement c'est
cette job en alternance parce que les
recruteurs n'était pas au rendez vous et
c'est bien logique avec cette crise
sanitaire avec l'absence de projection
aujourd'hui moi je trouve que les
étudiants ne sont pas pris en charge et
pas suffisamment et en charge et c'est
souvent aux collectivités locales n'est
rivaux départements et régions qui la
font les compléments mais
malheureusement l'état déplorant des
îles contassot est effectivement le
gouvernement qui mise sur la reprise
économique et les offres d'emplois
seraient 10 ans qui pullulent en ce
moment donc les étudiants qui pourraient
prétendre à ces emplois qu'en pensez
vous est ce que le gouvernement a raison
les offres d'emploi c'est dans le
secteur du bâtiment c'est dans le
secteur de l'hôtellerie restauration
c'est dans des secteurs qui sont assez
peu compatible en termes d'horaires ou
de conditions de travail la pénibilité
avec le fait de faire des études donc il
faut pas se raconter d'histoires c'est
pas du tout une capacité à voir des
emplois pour les étudiants mais moi je
vaux d'âge pas tout à fait d'accord
ce qui a été dit sur le fait que la
priorité devait être donnée aux
étudiants la priorité si pour tous les
jeunes qui galèrent tous les jeunes qui
galèrent et si quasiment tout le monde
dit qu'il faudra au minimum commencer
par rsa jeunes est en deçà aux 18 25 ans
c'est pas le fruit du hasard c'est que
ceux qui ne font pas études c'est pas
parce qu'ils ont choisi de ne pas faire
d'études beaucoup ils ont d'abord du mal
on voit avec les dispositifs parcours
super autres la complexité aujourd'hui
pour avoir accès à des études moi j'ai
dit les gamins autour de moi si on est
obligé de quitter paris pour aller à
compiègne pour aller très loin c'est les
mêmes problématiques avec des familles
modestes qui doit néanmoins payer un
logement
assez loin de paris etc tout ça on voit
bien que c'est l'ensemble des jeunes qui
devrait aider sans distinction alors en
revanche c'est vrai qu'il faut que cette
aide soit soumise quand ils sont
fiscalement rattachés aux parents bas
bien évidemment à la déclaration
d'impôts des parents pour éviter des
effets d'aubaine mais en dehors de ça
c'est l'ensemble des jeunes qui doivent
être aidés dans un premier temps avant
d'aller vers un revenu universel évident
tôt ou tard arrivera on le voit partout
dans le monde cette idée est en train de
progresser les études je reviens sur les
étudiants par exemple à orléans ce
week-end forte affluence encore pour la
distribution alimentaire 300 jeunes
étudiants qui sont en situation
financière compliquée d'autant que leur
parent euros a été supprimée pour les
non-boursiers écouter ce qu'on dit le
chargé de mission de la lutte contre la
précarité étudiante à orléans ont
justement
les aides sont arrêtés et c'était un peu
trop tôt il aurait peut-être fallu un
peu plus anticipé en se disant que la
crise est encore là pour les étudiants
et qu'il faut continuer l accompagner
financièrement encore un peu on n'a pas
beaucoup on en a pas beaucoup entendu
parler david xavier weiss mais leur part
un euro c'est fini pour ceux qui ne sont
plus boursier est là le quoi qu'il en
coûte il ne s'applique pas visiblement
aux étudiants
de toute façon on a bien vu que le
gouvernement avait dit le quoi qu'il en
coûte et était fini derrière nous et
effectivement je ne suis pas du tout
d'accord avec eux je suis content assaut
sur les priorités quand on dit qu'elle
est priorité il faut d'abord cibler des
publics prioritaires donc moi je pense
qu'il faut aider les étudiants ces sont
les étudiants qui pour beaucoup
d'efforts s'ils sont parfois obligés de
quitter donc leur foyer familial et donc
de trouver un logement et un job pour
les pour pour pau pour y subvenir et
c'est passé si tu veux on finalement
qu'on leur dit pas plus dead les appels
qui baisse et plus de repas en tout cas
des repas beaucoup plus cher et c'est
finalement aux collectivités locales qui
derrière
sur
contrepartie ou en tout cas essaye de
les accompagner ont fait nous par
exemple le ballon on accompagne les
jeunes qui sont en difficulté via aussi
via nos commerçants et des restaurateurs
qui ont fait des repas le midi est les
tarifs très préférentiels pour les
étudiants et
c'est comme ça qu'il faut un maximum
accompagner et prioriser ces aides on
sait très bien que je sais très bien que
les écolos prônent la décroissance
économique mais on compte apprenez et la
décroissance économique et augmenter les
aides à tout le monde mais je
préférerais qu'on parle de décroissance
démographique et est partagée finalement
un gâteau plus large parce que là c'est
incompatible ont pu valider tous les
jeunes c'est pas vrai priorisons pour
les étudiants dans un premier temps et
si la même heure soit et la ressource
fiscale et la manne financière du goût
du gouvernement et des pays occidentaux
exploitant mieux je suis pas sûr que ce
soit pour demain mais tant mieux et à ce
moment là donc pourra reparler dans
universel mais d'abord puis à voter pour
les jeunes étudiants ont pris oui les
réal girard yves contassot oui aussi le
discours traditionnel de la droite
faisons en sorte que ceux qui ont les
moyens on est un peu plus quand on voit
la suppression de l' isf quand on voit
ce qui est donné aux entreprises + 40
milliards et qu'on nous dise n'a pas
l'argent pour des jeunes qui sont en
difficulté c'est franchement un choix
c'est effectivement un choix de classe
faut dire les choses comme elles sont et
c'est pas une question croissance ou
décroissance une question de partage de
la richesse et de réduction des
inégalités
mais non non non c'est pas de la
démagogie vous n'osez pas dire non je
suis désolé vous n'osez pas dire que
vous êtes dans la logique de et d'autres
élèves
on n'a pas la même conception de ce que
la pauvreté est de ceux qui
manifestent de moi j'en voie
électrifiée
je vois pas que
alors les séparer de xavier weill parce
que c'est vrai que quand on est à
distance c'est un peu plus compliqué je
vous en prie les tueurs ne sont pas des
nantis contrairement à ce que vous
pensiez monsieur propre un seau et
qu'ils habitent levallois ou ailleurs
les situent les étudiants quand ils sont
entre interviews leurs études et
travailler à côté pour financer leur
logement parfois les chambres de bonne
de 9 mais qui allaient dans paris ou
voire moins de 29 balles carrées je vous
défie de trucs de dire que ce sont des
nantis et c'est d'ailleurs une insulte à
tous les étudiants que vous busy mans
vous ne connaissez pas côtoyer pas parce
que moi je les côtoie et j'en reçois
beaucoup tout où les voir de voir toutes
les semaines
les étudiants ne sont pas des gentils il
faut d'abord les prix ils étaient
presque tous les étudiants ou les jeunes
qui sont encore chez leurs parents ont
peut-être besoin de moins dead que ceux
qui sont partis de chez eux et qu'ils
doivent assumer un loyer lanouf et un
job l institut la place
cette façon de mentir en disant que j'ai
traité les étudiants dentistes est assez
typique hélas d'un niveau de débat
politique qui se dégrade de jour en jour
je n'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit qu'il y
avait des gens en qui était encore plus
en difficulté ce qui n'a rien à voir je
sais et je connais bien la situation des
étudiants croyez moi au moins aussi bien
que vous simplement je dis qu'il ya des
gens qui sont donc des galères encore
plus important parce qu'ils n'ont pas de
travail parce qu'ils n'ont personne pour
les aider vous savez ce que c'est que de
vivre dans certains quartiers dans
certaines municipalités en ile de france
ou ailleurs quand ya pas de boulot quand
un des deux parents est au chômage et
qui a pas les moyens de trouver du
boulot et là il faudrait pas laisser des
non plus le jeu il faudra nourrir
débrouille toi un jour peut-être y aura
du boulot non c'est pas sérieux je pense
que les très beaux et ils sont très
nombreux en france les chiffres sont là
le reportage qui était juste avant notre
débat l'illustré mérite effectivement
qu'on redonne quelque chose à ces jeunes
qui sont très très grande difficulté et
pas en les triant com vous proposait en
parle beaucoup de pouvoir d'achat je
moi je préfère de une priorité aux
jeunes étudiants c'est chacun sa vision
je pense que même ma vision est
respectable autant que la vôtre et elle
est beaucoup plus réaliste parce que je
pourrais très bien démago en disant
voilà on va faire un chèque de 1000
euros à tous les jeunes je peux je peux
me lancer dans la démagogie sauf que
c'est pas finançable et c'est pas
réaliste je préfère qu'on dise dans un
premier temps si on si les ressources
fiscales le permettent et bien et non
écrit horizons les jeunes étudiants qui
veut font des efforts qui eux ont des
difficultés au quotidien parce que
justement comme ils sont étudiants ayant
dû quitter le foyer il est donc se
trouver un job pour financer leur
appartement et notamment à paris où
c'est très cher en tout cas à paris en
région parisienne et dans des côtes des
grosses agglomérations le logement est
très chère et là il est logique voilà
j'ai pour moi je peux je peux me lancer
dans la démagogie ld réagi en disant
faisons un chèque en blanc à tous les
jeunes c'est pas si tu as ma façon de
faire je préfère être honnête et
transparent reste pour les choix là il
nous reste très peu de temps je voudrais
une réaction à ce qu'a dit matthieu
orphelin dans une tribune publiée dans
le journal le monde il critique les les
préjugés sur l'assistanat présumée dès
qu'on verse des aides financières
écouter
le gouvernement devrait arrêter de jouer
sur l'idée que trop d'allocation est un
frein au retour à l'emploi
cette intuition sur l'assistanat nourrie
par la présomption de fainéantise
défendu largement par une partie de la
classe politique notamment à droite et
chez la république en marche est une
idée reçue jamais vérifié il comptait
swing une réaction le pouvoir d'achat
des étudiants on a pris un coup 2,5 pour
cent alors que l'inflation est à 1,2
c'est plus que la moyenne des français
oui mais bien sûr il ya aujourd'hui une
paupérisation qui est en train de se
généraliser
vous prenez les étudiants mais ou poney
pouvait prendre aussi les enseignants
moins 30% de baisse pardon 30% de baisse
par rapport au salaire moyen l'espace
d'une dizaine d'années on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une tendance baissé
à tirer tous les revenus vers le bas
pendant que les plus riches
effectivement vous l'avez démontré
s'enrichissent tu es là c'est toute la
différence entre effectivement ceux qui
pensent qu'il devienne la solidarité
d'abord plutôt que de la charité et de
l'assistanat au mauvais sens du terme
pour le retour à l'emploi
écoutez ça fait ça fait et moi depuis 50
ans que j'entends dire le plein emploi
le plein emploi et c'est toujours demain
il y aura le plein emploi j'ai connu les
plans barre j'ai connu tous les plans de
relance et le plein emploi il n'a pas
existé en france quasiment depuis ma
jeunesse alors faut arrêter de nous
raconter des sornettes en audience oui
mais avec mon parti je vais y arriver
c'est pas vrai aujourd'hui c'est pas à
l'ordre du jour malheureusement
cette présomption de fainéantise
oui non je suis pas sur le fait de jeter
l'anathème à priori sur tel ou tel mais
on voit bien que ce sont bien les
étudiants qui ont le plus souffert dans
cette crise et du rhin crise qui va
venir aussi parce qu'on est à la veille
d'une crise économique et un corps sont
à 2500 milliards d'euros tête on sait
très bien que la crise allait surtout
pour demain et on voit bien ce sont
aujourd'hui les étudiants et demain
encore les étudiants qui vont payer le
prix fort au delà de la catégorisation
des jeunes en général qui est trop trop
vague et dont les étudiants c'est la
priorité est pour le moment le
gouvernement dans des lieux marc on ne
le prévoit pas et on ne le fait pas je
sais que ce dernier sondage pour finir
60% des jeunes pense effectivement que
les étudiants ont été les grands oubliés
de cette crise un sanitaire merci
beaucoup à tous les deux on a encore
beaucoup à dire malheureusement nous
n'avons plus le temps ce matin merci
beaucoup d'avoir débattue ce matin en
direct sur le plateau d'ayrté france
mais chez vous